hey guys I wanted to do a video on the
worst and best carb on keto okay the
worst carb is fructose okay it's a sugar
but it's still a carb now here's what
you need to know about fructose table
sugar has about 50% glucose and 50%
fructose high fructose corn syrup has
about 55% fructose in 45% glucose agave
nectar has like 90% fructose so this is
the worst and then fruit does have
fructose but it has a lot of fiber
phytonutrients vitamins and minerals so
even though it has fructose it doesn't
nearly create the damage but it will
stop you from getting into ketosis
simply because they've been breeding
fruit very very sweet and high in sugar
the only thing I would recommend related
to that would be certain barriers like
raspberry and blackberries they're very
low if you had like a couple of those a
day I think that would be fine instead
of the fruits like the apples and the
pears and the grapes which are very very
sweet so that's my point about that but
let's just get back to fructose glucose
will increase insulin because all of the
cells can absorb glucose but not all the
cells can deal with fructose mainly the
liver okay so all the fructose goes to
your liver and the liver is forced to
deal with this
fructose now the amount of people that
are drinking their fructose in sodas and
juice incredible amounts so it creates
some serious damage because it will turn
into fat in the liver it will give you a
fatty liver which will then cause
insulin resistance and make your insulin
spike
so fructose indirectly will raise the
insulin and create even more damage to
the body because the liver gets
overloaded and then you're going to get
a fight of liver and then the capacity
to handle it goes down there's a lot of
problems so consuming fructose is very
similar to consuming alcohol as far as
the damage on the liver okay so fructose
is the worst all right the best car are
all the leafy greens the vegetables why
because they have high fiber very low
calories very low on the glycemic index
they will not throw you out of ketosis
so I don't even count them in the
mackerel equation when you're doing the
keto plan so you want to consume as many
vegetables as you can as far as leafy
greens on this plan okay well thanks for
watching hey guys so I'm doing a survey
of a future video and I wanted to find
out what your biggest body problem is so
that way the content is aligning with
something that you are personally
interested in so please click the link
down below fill it out and I will create
the video thanks